another thing I wanted to say is you
actually had a residency at Planet
Hollywood right and I'm about to have
one so did you love it you're gonna love
it okay I'm a little nervous just cause
it's real drag no no no no no forget
about anything you've ever heard about
that the stereotype of that the beauty
of it is you play the show and you go
home at night yeah and the same place
and it's the same with listen you have
to understand when we do a world tour
it's literally fly play fly play
occasionally you'll sleep Planet
Hollywood it's gonna be so great for you
because it's the crowd is adorable
number one anything you say or do
they're gonna you're a talker so you
have to understand what makes it so
wonderful is we talk to them we don't
just sing we interact with be a part of
the show I mean cuz if you just wanted
the music you could just close your eyes
and imagine the show and you're going to
love it you're going to love I'm excited
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this